we begin in the occupied West Bank where
Israeli forces have killed a 99-year-old
Palestinian boy and a 15-year-old
teenager during a raid in Janine just a
warning some of her viewers may find the
following pictures disturbing so there's
the footage right there it shows the
moment they were shot by Israeli forces
and this comes after Israel's Army
raided Janine for hours and declared the
area a closed military zone Israeli
soldiers stormed the city and the
refugee camp with armored vehicles and
bulldozers we'll get more on this from
Charles Stratford Charles you're joining
us from the Janine refugee camp in the
occupied West Bank and we've just gotten
these pictures showing uh these boys uh
looks like they they were targeted
obviously they've been killed tell us
what you've been
hearing yes that's right this this raid
is being described by residents here
inside the Janine refugee camp as being
the largest raid they can remember
certainly since the beginning of the war
and yes some truly horrific footage
video footage has appeared of the
shooting of these two young boys the
Palestinian Authority is saying that it
was an 8-year-old that was shot in the
back according to people that we've
spoken to he was playing football at the
time as the Israeli forces were
withdrawing that's after a raid that
lasted around 17 hours um and seemingly
defenseless as you see there shot in the
back being dragged under a car or behind
a car by one of his friends what
evidence would suggest um and also yes a
a 15-year-old boy also killed during
this raid that's according to the pa um
and as I say this is being described as
one of the largest Israeli military R
the largest military raid since the
beginning of the war um residents are
describing there being hundreds of
soldiers that not only came into the
camp but something that they hadn't seen
since the beginning of the war soldiers
walking around the town as well as you
rightly say it was described as a closed
military zone for hours we spoke to the
owner of the house that was destroyed
during this raid it seems like the
Israeli forces were targeting specific
leaders of the Armed resistance groups
that operate inside Janine now the owner
of this house and as I say the house is
completely completely destroyed he says
that he was hiding in his house with his
family and then became aware that there
may have been Palestinian fighters in
the house there hiding also and he says
that one of his children actually saw
one of these small Israeli military
drones come through we understand a hole
in the wall inside the house and it was
then that the house was destroyed even
further um and once the Israelis um had
left they uncovered certainly according
to to the owner of the house they
uncovered one body of a Palestinian
fighter under the rubble but most
interestingly as well and there's film
footage certainly photographic footage
of this one of these bodies was put
inside the scoop of one of the Israeli
armored bulldozers and taken away now
subsequent to this literally in the last
hour or so the Israeli military have put
a statement out they said they described
this as a joint operation between the
IDF that's the Israeli Defense Force is
what we call the Israeli Army shinb
which is their intelligence service and
special forces and they say that they in
that operation killed two what they
describe as high ranking in their words
terrorists including the commander of
the camp a man called Muhammad zubedi
now Muhammad zubedi as you can imagine
was very well known here and was very
well respected amongst the armed
resistance groups the Israelis are
accusing him of being involved in
various different attacks shooting
attacks um in recent months and being
behind possibly the supply of of
vehicles it's unclear in this statement
but it implies possibly Vehicles even
used during the attacks that we saw on
October the 7th but as I say that is
unclear right um they go on to say that
there were confiscations of various
weapons um explosive devices and a lathe
the Israeli Army say was being used to
make weapons um and they say that since
the War Began on October the 7th this is
the Israeli Army they're saying that um
2,000 wanted persons have been arrested
across Judea and Samaria which is what
Israel calls the occupied West Bank well
bear in mind according to the
Palestinian prisoner Association that
number needs to be a lot higher they're
saying
3,300 have been arrested so a huge
disparity in numbers there but as I say
the Israeli is saying that it's 2,000
wanted persons that they have arrested
since the beginning of their War okay
Charles thank you for keeping us across
this developing story Charles statford
is reporting from the Janine refugee
camp